MICHEAL O FOGHLU:
Good morning, Krakow.
My name's is Micheal.
I'm Irish, but I'm working
in the Munich office.
And I'm here to tell you about
Google engineering in Europe.
Google's a fun
place for engineers
to work and help to
create products that
have a really global impact.
But before I get
into the talk, I just
want you to think a bit about
what end users of Google
products think about Google.
Probably the first
thing they think about
is Google's search engine.
And then I want you to think
about what sort of company
is Google.
What are we?
We're one of the
biggest companies
in the world in terms of
revenues and market cap
and so on.
But if you think about what
sort of company we are,
we started out as
a search company,
but now we're much more
than a search company.
And people in this
audience probably
have a good idea of what we are.
We're a company that
produces a lot of products.
And all of these products
are this strange new thing
that didn't exist 100 years ago,
software products, strangely
ephemeral, based on
layers of abstraction that
keep changing every five
years, or every two months
if you're in JavaScript.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, if you think about what it
takes to build these products,
essentially this means that
we're a software company.
And so we know about software.
And we love our own developers,
and we love you, our developer
community.
So this means that our products
are more than just products.
They're things that
people use to help
create real impact globally.
And every one of our
hundreds of products
has potentially billions
of success stories
of people using them to
really change their lives.
And very importantly, in
terms of Google's philosophy,
even though we started as an
American company in Silicon
Valley, like many other software
companies, from the get go,
our vision has been
a global vision.
And our vision has been that
the internet and the services
and products that we provide
are for absolutely everyone
on the planet, not just
for English speakers,
not just for North Americans,
not just for Europeans,
but globally.
And we've put a huge amount of
investment of time and effort
and energy into trying
to make this vision real,
and we certainly have
got a long way there.
If you look at
the globe, we have
users in all corners
of the globe using
all of our products.
Now I'm going to focus in
on what we're doing here
in Europe in terms
of engineering,
because you may think that our
engineering products are all
developed in America.
But in fact, we're
a global company,
and we have a very, very
significant presence
here in Europe.
These dots represent
our engineering offices,
not all of our offices, in
EMEA, Europe, the Middle East,
and Africa.
This includes Zurich, Dublin,
London, Munich, Paris, Aarhus,
Stockholm, and Warsaw,
and Tel Aviv in Israel.
Famously, Google
has seven products
that have more than a billion
users, and some of them
with more than
two billion users.
And every one of these products
has a significant engineering
effort here in Europe.
At its simplest,
there's two main types
of engineers in Google.
There are what we call
SWEs, Software Engineers.
And there are what we call SREs,
Site Reliability Engineers.
Because so many of our products
are hosted internet services,
we need to place
just as much emphasis
on keeping things up
and running and keeping
latencies low and so on
and so forth, as we do
on actually developing and
building the software itself.
And it takes both
types of engineers
to make products work.
And of course,
there's a whole slew
of other supporting engineers.
I don't mean to
miss anybody out,
but it includes UX and design
and all sorts of other types--
and security and
all sorts of things.
But principally, Google
thinks about these engineers
as falling into
these two categories.
If you think about where some
of this activity takes place,
just to call out three,
Android has a huge base
in London and Aarghus.
Chrome has a huge base
in Munich and Paris.
And Google Play Store has a big
base in London and in Zurich.
Now, as well as creating
products for consumers,
we also create products
for developers.
And there's a number of
different types of products
that we create for developers.
So probably the
most obvious one,
which has a huge presence
here at this event,
is the Google Cloud Platform.
And much of that effort
takes place here in Poland,
in Warsaw.
And the next speaker,
Ewa, will be giving you
some details about
what's actually
going on there in that office.
As well as that, we
have sort of APIs
that can be reused by developers
that are part of Google Cloud
Platform but almost come from
a separate engineering effort.
And in Europe, a lot of that
effort is focused in Zurich.
For our next talk
after Ewa, we have
Behshad, who'll be telling you
all about Google Assistant.
And you'll be able
to engage then
here in the conference
in code labs and so on
and using AI in
your own services.
We also have a set of
external developer tools
that we link to the
Google Cloud Platform.
And because we ourselves
are full of developers
and we need to
support them, we've
a set of internal
developer tools.
And a lot of that effort goes
on in my home office in Munich.
And then we have,
like any company does,
corporate applications
that are for all users,
not just for developers.
And a lot of that effort
happens in Munich and London.
And why do we do all this?
So that you have the tools
to build cool products
and services for your own users.
Now, as this is mainly
a developer audience,
I just want to give you a
bit of a feel about the scale
that we operate in in our
own software inside Google.
For comparison, let's just
look at the Linux 4.2 codebase
at roughly 20
million lines of code
and 50,000 files,
quite a big codebase.
We change that amount of code
in our codebase in Google
every week.
In fact, more than
that number of files
gets changed every week.
If you look at the bigger
stats, internally we
have more than 40,000
developers working
on a single integrated
mono repo codebase that's
made up of a billion files
and nine million source files
and two billion lines of code.
And we're working furiously
at this every day.
And code review is a critical
part of Google's code culture,
so we have over 20,000 code
reviews happening per workday.
Nobody's allowed to check
stuff into the master repo
without it being reviewed on
a number of different vectors.
And this leads to thousands
of commits per week.
And interestingly,
over time, we've
invested so much in
our internal tooling,
that there's a
much higher growth
rate of automated
changes to our codebase
than human-based changes.
But also quite interestingly,
these automated changes
also seem to have breaks
in the holidays, right?
So the robots take holidays too.
And our tooling is vast, and
we've invested very, very
heavily in it.
And the tooling group
that I worked for
is called DevTAS, Developer
Tools and Signals.
And we're in charge of
this internal tooling
for internal codebase
that we call Google 3.
And there's a set of
probably 20 to 50 tools
in these various categories
that help build our software
and keep it current
and keep it regular.
I want to call out
just one of these tools
that we've externalized
as open source.
It's a tool called Bazel.
It'll be particularly
interesting to any of you who
are working on very
large codebases
and you want to try and
optimize build times,
because it allows you to store
a graph of all the builds
that anyone in the
company has done.
And if you can cache those
builds, when the builds are
then done again, only the
stuff that hasn't already
been compiled needs
to be recompiled.
And you can reuse the
binaries from anywhere
in the organization.
And we use a version of
this internally in Google
called Blaze, and it's one of
the core productivity tools
that we have.
Now, Bazel is open source, and
it's not yet at version 1.0.
But already it's being used by
companies like Dropbox, Huawei,
and Stripe.
So especially if you're
working on large codebases,
you might be very
interested in Bazel.
In terms of our
philosophy then, we
have a slightly unique way
of doing things in Google,
using our single mono repo.
And it's actually our
own tool called Piper.
Again, one of my
teams works on that.
And we started off
using Perforce,
and we outgrew it in
terms of our scale.
So we needed to build our
own replacement for it.
Mandatory code reviews, fast
builds from source at head
using Blaze,
ruthless refactoring
and identifying breaking
changes with automated testing,
maintaining a green build
and frequent releases--
in fact, anything running in
our own internal cloud that's
running for more than six
months without an update
is a red flag, and people
have to revisit it.
And this is to make sure that
we're constantly recompiling
all of our services with
the latest libraries
to make sure that we're not
opening any vulnerabilities.
If you look at the news today,
anyone who develops in Java,
check out the
Struts vulnerability
that was just announced.
It's quite scary.
You may be recompiling
some code tonight.
So to take it all
back then, we are
trying to invest in software.
We have an internal
community, and we
have an external
community, and we're
trying to take as much knowledge
from our internal community
to share with the external
community in terms of tools,
services, and products.
And now we've
realized that we need
to also invest in communication
and events like this.
And this event is
one example of this,
trying to host more events
here in Europe, where,
as was mentioned in the
opening keynote on day one,
we know that there are
more software developers
than in the North America--
the US and Canada combined.
Last month, for example,
we had the Polymer Summit
in Copenhagen and Denmark.
And next month, we have the
Firebase Summit in Amsterdam
in the Netherlands.
And it's particularly
cool how you can hook up
Firebase with Cloud Functions
from the Google Cloud Platform
to create a very lightweight
serverless backend
to very complex applications.
And any of you who
are working in mobile
might be interested in that.
So I'm now going to
pass you over to someone
who will do a deeper dive
into the Google Cloud Platform
and who works here
in Europe, Ewa, who
works in our Warsaw office.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
EWA MACIAS: Thank you.
Hello.
My name is Ewa Macias,
and I'm leading
Cloud Frontend team,
one of the engineering
teams we have in Poland.
I'm very happy to be
here today in Krakow.
I counted, and I spent about
43% of my entire life in Krakow
and about 88% of my adult life.
I was studying here and then
spent the first eight years
at Google here.
It's really good to be back.
And I'm proud that I'm
representing our Google Poland
office here today and to tell
you a little bit about what
we are focusing on.
Over the last
decade, Google Poland
has focused its effort on
technical infrastructure.
We build products
and systems that
are part of the Google
internet platform, where
all services, like Search and
YouTube and Gmail are running.
We build software
throughout multiple layers,
from an agent running on every
single machine in Google data
centers, through a massive data
collection and the processing,
to web user interface.
A major theme for
us over the years
has been automation and
improving user interaction
with the infrastructure so that
the internal teams can spend
less time doing operations
work and more time
developing actual
business logic.
Here's one example of
our automation focus.
We build a system
that, for a service,
automatically chooses a
data center to run on based
on the service requirements.
It also decides
how many resources
to allocate for a service
and decides how many copies
of the service to run.
When we got started here in
Poland over 10 years ago,
the industry was running
mostly on private data centers,
maintaining large
specialized servers.
These days, almost
everyone is looking
at how to move the cloud,
because it's expensive
and time consuming to
maintain infrastructure.
And it also takes you away
from your core business.
So for the last four years
we focused our efforts
on exposing the
internal infrastructure
to our external users.
And the resulting
product is known today
as Google Cloud Platform.
Why developers choose use Cloud?
Because it's built on
the same infrastructure
as all other services at Google,
and it offers security, scale,
and cost efficiency,
access to a global network,
best-in-class data
processing tools,
access to services like machine
learning, and most importantly,
velocity.
You can see here on the
slide some quotes directly
from our customers.
I could stand here probably
for all day telling you
a lot of details about GCP.
But since we don't have that
much time, the rest of my talk
will focus on the product
known as Cloud Compute,
because this is what our
team in Poland is working on.
In Cloud Compute, our
mission is to help
you find a perfect engine
for your workloads.
>From serverless environments to
containers to virtual machines,
we are working to
provide a scalable range
of compute options
to match your needs.
Specifically, Cloud
Compute offers four places
[? where ?] you can
run your software--
Compute Engine, Container
Engine, App Engine,
and Cloud Functions.
Now when I look at this
slide, maybe Cloud Functions
should be renamed
to Functions Engine.
My slides would look
much better then.
Look at the slide as a spectrum.
The lower in the stack, the
more flexibility and control
you have.
The higher in the
stack, the more
automation Google provides.
In other words, in
the lower layer,
you get almost [? no ?]
infrastructure.
In the highest layer,
you just bring your code,
your business logic, and Google
will do the rest for you.
I'm going to walk you
through the four platforms
to give you an understanding
of what they are
and how you might
want to use them.
And I will also point
out some specific things
that we are working
on here in Poland.
So let's start from the
bottom, Compute Engine.
Compute Engine offers
virtual machines.
Think about virtual machines
as your personal computer,
only that it's not on your
desk, but it's remote.
It's in the Google data center.
And you can access it remotely.
So let me now show you
how to get a server on GC
in a few seconds.
I will do a live demo,
so fingers crossed.
So this is Cloud Console.
It's a web interface where
you can create and manage
your GCP resources.
It's a really good place to
start exploring the platform.
See here are the four
platforms I'm presenting today.
But you can get
access to many more,
like storage and networking and
machine learning, everything.
So let's go to the Compute
Engine and create an instance.
When you create an instance,
you can decide how big it is.
You can get anything from
one core to 64 cores,
and you can get up to
416 gigabytes of memory.
We have a wide range
of pre-cooked images,
Linux distributions,
and Windows Server.
You can also bring
your own image.
If you want this instance
to run web traffic,
you want to probably
enable HTTP, HTTPS.
By default, all the VMs
are protected by firewalls
from the traffic from internet.
Before I go ahead
and create this VM,
I want to show you
one cool thing.
Many users, when they get
more familiar with the GCP,
they tend to prefer
come online over the UI
and its natural process.
But this web UI
is a very good way
to learn command line
too, and transition
to command line later.
For almost everything that
you can do in this UI,
you can get [? a ?]
valid command line.
So this is the command
line for the VM.
And the cool thing is that
you can run it directly
from the browser.
Whoops.
So you don't have to install
G Cloud or configure anything
on your computer.
All you need is the browser.
So let's go ahead
and create a VM.
Booting the VM and
programming the network
takes like 20, 30 seconds.
And so there's one more
cool thing I want to show.
So when you have the
server up and running,
you want to SSH
to it, and you can
start installing
basically any software
you like on the server.
And you can also SSH
directly from the UI.
Let's go.
We are in this inside
of the VM, and you
can start browsing as in
the normal virtual machine.
I really also wanted
to do this demo
because this Frontend
for Cloud Compute
is being built in Warsaw.
[APPLAUSE]
Woo-hoo.
One thing that I would
like to point out
is that sometimes it
can be hard to decide
upfront what is the
right size of the machine
for your service.
To help with that,
GCP will observe
the load of the
VM and the traffic
and will recommend
you the best size,
either decrease it
to save you money,
or increase it for a
better performance.
This recommendation engine is
being built in Poland as well.
[APPLAUSE]
Together with the VMs and
access to a global network,
you also get a set of tools that
help you manage the service.
One of them is autoscaling
groups of instances.
You can configure
it so it always
keeps a certain amount of
instances up and running.
The system does it by
observing the health
and recreating the VM
if they go unhealthy.
You can also attach
an autoscaler
that will observe the CPU
load and add or remove
the servers based on your
metric or on the traffic going
on the CPU load.
So you still have a
full control over what
is running on that VM.
But you apply an
automation that helps
you run the service in a
cost-efficient and reliable
way.
And autoscaler and
many other tools
that help you
manage GC instances
are also being built in Poland.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, let's go one
level up to Container Engine.
Container Engine is our
hosted Kubernetes environment.
And as you might
guess from its name,
it's a platform for running
a large number of containers.
It handles a lot
of infrastructure,
which is for you like virtual
machines and networking.
And by using the open
source Kubernetes,
it also manages the containers
for you automatically.
What are containers?
I like thinking about
containers as a lighter
version of virtual machines.
They are software
packaging units
that only take your
code and libraries
and make them independent
from the operating system
so that you can run
multiple containers on one
VM in isolation.
Unlike virtual machines, they
do not contain operating system,
so they are much
smaller in bytes
and they start much faster.
What are Kubernetes?
Usually you put just one
thing into a container,
like web server or
database, for example.
So when you want to start
building a system out
of your containers, you usually
end up having a lot of them.
And maintaining a lot of
containers can be challenging.
So let me give you one example.
Let's say I want to have
a three-layer application,
database, backend, and frontend.
So I package them
into three containers.
For redundancy, I want to have
a couple of instances of each.
I want to have the frontend
accessible via public IP
address and two upper
layers autoscaled.
such a relatively simple service
can be challenging to maintain.
So here's where
Kubernetes comes in.
They will start that up for
you and make sure it stays up
and running.
Some of you may have heard or
played the game "Pokemon Go."
This slide will show
how fast the game
was growing in the first
days of its popularity.
So this line shows
the estimates traffic.
The green line is the
[INAUDIBLE] disaster scenario.
And the blue line
is the real traffic.
So it was a huge
success of the game.
And it was also a huge success
of the Google Container Engine,
because the platform actually
managed to scale for the game.
And I'm very proud to say that
Google Poland is contributing
to both Kubernetes and
GKE, and specifically, they
are working on the
scalability of the platform.
Now let's go another
layer up to App Engine.
App Engine is optimized to run
your web code extremely well.
The motto of App Engine
is bring your code,
and we'll do the rest for you.
So you don't have to think
about operating system
or virtual machines or any
other piece of infrastructure
when you use App Engine.
This is called
serverless environment.
It doesn't mean that the
server doesn't exist.
It only means that from the
perspective of a developer,
the server is invisible.
All you see when you implement
and manage and deploy your app
are application-level
constructs.
App Engine also
offers a very rich set
of tools crafted for
web applications,
like traffic splitting,
security scanner, versioning,
and incredibly rapid scaling.
The last piece of our
spectrums is Cloud Functions.
It also is a
serverless environment.
But from the perspective
of a developer,
it's even simpler
than App Engine.
And it can be seen as glue that
enables you to very easily use
many Google services, like
Speech Recognition API
and Vision API or listen
to changes in a database.
With Cloud Functions,
you can almost
forget about the concept
of an application.
All you see or all
you think about when
you use Cloud Functions is
your code, your function,
and an event on which the
function should be executed.
So let me show
you how you do it.
A classical example
is sending an email
to a user when they upload
an image to a database.
So let's go to Cloud Functions.
I will create a function,
upload an image to a storage,
and observe that the
function was executed.
So I chose a trigger,
cloud storage bucket.
I specify the bucket that
will be observed for changes.
And here's my code.
I will not be sending
email in this demo.
We don't have that much time.
I will just pretend.
And one small detail--
I need to specify a bucket
where my source code will
be stored, and create.
Now I will go to the storage.
Let's see the trigger.
We are in the storage UI.
And I'm uploading a file.
Let's say a dog image.
Please upload.
Oh, woo-hoo!
Yes, the file is there.
[APPLAUSE]
Success.
So now let's go and see whether
the function was executed.
I go to Logs.
Since we are in
the source code, we
are logging the fact that the
function has been executed.
And all right, the logs is
not there, not there yet.
All right, we have something.
Do we have a dog?
We have a cat.
We have a dog,
and we have a cat.
So let's go back to
the presentation.
So you see, that was easy.
That was like a couple of
clicks and lines of code.
And all the glue between
your code and the storage,
in particular,
listening to the changes
and making sure that
your function really gets
executed at least once,
all that is handled
for you by the platform.
As some of you may
heard yesterday,
Cloud functions also can
be used with Firebase.
And it's very powerful way
for the mobile developers
to build server side
extensions without having
to learn, or manage,
or understand, or deal
with any servers.
And Cloud Functions are 100%
designed and built in Warsaw.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so a quick
recap of the presentation.
When you use Compute Engine, you
think about virtual machines,
operating system, and
network, basically virtual
infrastructure.
Containers take you from the
world of virtual machines
to microservices,
containers, and applications.
When you use App Engine,
you choose to abstract away
from the infrastructure.
And all you see or care about is
application and HTTP requests.
And finally, when you
use Cloud Functions,
you solely operate on a
piece of code, your function,
and events.
So now when I highlighted the
differences between the four
platforms, you might
be asking yourself,
so which one I should be using?
My recommendation is
that you go from the top.
Check whether the
platforms work for you
and whether it's not
constraining you too much.
And if it's not, just take it.
If it is constraining
you too much,
it means that you need more
flexibility and control, so
go one level down.
Google Cloud Platform
has really a lot to offer
and we are very excited
about its future.
So if you are interested
in learning more about it,
I encourage you to go
to the Cloud console
or to cloud.google.com
and start exploring.
I also will be around
here today if you
want to ask me any questions.
So now I would like to introduce
my colleague, Behshad Bezhadi,
from Zurich office.
He's a senior
engineering director
and he's leading a team
of over 100 engineers
building Google Assistant.
Welcome Behshad on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI:
Hello everybody.
My name is Behshad and I
work on the Google Assistant
team in Zurich office.
Yesterday, Tilke talked
about the different ways
that you can bring the
power of Google Assistant
into your own applications
through the actions on Google
Platform.
Today I want to talk about
what we in Google are
doing to improve the Google
Assistant across devices.
So in Google I/O, Sundar
sent this key message,
which is the next 10 years is
going to be an AI-first world.
And I'm personally very
excited about that,
because I consider
Google Assistant
and building an
assistant is actually
one of the core implementations
of such a AI world.
So in some way, we
feel that we are
part of building
this next revolution.
But before going and talking
more about the Google Assistant
itself, I want to talk a little
bit about this AI revolution.
The AI revolution
is in some ways
similar to some of the bigger
revolutions which happened
through the past 100 years.
These were revolutions where
they changed the life of lots
of people, they made lots
of companies to disappear,
lots of new companies appeared,
and they're actually saving
lots of time from people.
If you think about phone,
car, plane, and transistor.
For example, just
consider the plane.
Before that, 100
years ago, if you
wanted to go from Europe to US,
you needed a month on a ship,
and only some people
could do that.
Today you do it in one
day or less than one day,
it's 10 hours, and that's
basically about saving time.
Life of people is changing.
Now, if we move fast
forward towards newer types
of revolutions which
happened around 20 years ago
is about PC and internet.
So all of a sudden
at home we got
connected to the information.
So we didn't need
to go to the library
if you wanted to find how tall
is the Empire State Building.
And it really, if you
think about 20 years ago,
that was the only way to find
the answers to such questions.
So this is a big change,
again, into people's life.
You don't need to go
to a bank to check
what's your bank account.
You can buy things from home.
And you don't need to wait
for the next news on TV
to know what's the weather
going to be tomorrow.
You can just ask it.
But the next revolution happened
soon after, less than 10 years,
and that's the
mobile revolution,
which was even bigger
than the previous one.
Because the huge PC which was
in the corner of your home
before now is replaced
by these mobile phones,
which is smaller and
is in your pocket.
And you can bring it everywhere.
It's actually, in some
way, more powerful
because it has a camera,
it has a microphone,
and it's more personal.
You can take pictures, share,
and communicate, and more.
Mobile made our thinking at
Google about product different.
So we became really a
mobile-first company
from those moments.
However, the mobile
revolution is still ongoing.
And we kind of predict
that by 2020, there
is going to be 5 billion mobile
users on this planet, which
means that really, the scale is
bigger than the PC and the web
revolution which was
happening before.
This is because of cost and
bringing this to emerging
market is much easier.
This revolution is ongoing,
but the next revolution
is happening now, and it's
bringing this revolution
to the next level.
And that's the AI revolution.
This is where, for example,
in the case of mobiles,
we are trying to make the
interactions with mobile
to be conversational,
much more natural.
Make the smartphones
smart, and then
make them to understand
intent, understand context,
and answer things based on what
they hear and what they see.
When we have these experiences
through a conversation
with mobiles, we can expand that
to all types of other devices
too.
So if you're at car,
at your watch, at home,
you can use the same
conversational experience
and try to add that intelligence
in a very consistent way
through all your devices
in different places.
And now, I repeatedly say
conversation, conversation,
and this is really
the core of what
we think about Google Assistant,
because we kind of think
that conversation is
the most used interface
human beings have--
human beings have used.
We all know how to
talk from when we
are a kid to when we are old.
Old is not tall necessarily.
But from different
race, different ages,
people know how to interact
with each other through talking.
So if we solve that problem of
conversational understanding,
we have solved a big problem,
and then we can expand that
to many use cases.
So I think the best
would be now to--
I mean, I want to show
you a Google Assistant.
And I would like to invite
the camera man to come,
and I will to go to my
live demos, which is
going to be quite risky for me.
These are all live demos.
And you will have fun seeing
me being scared, I guess.
So here on my phone
I'm going to show you
lots of demos of showing
where we are today
with Google
Assistant development
and on different aspects
of what Assistant is doing.
So the first thing
I will show is
about how Google Assistant
is answering things today.
Let's start with hi,
Google, how are you doing?
AUTOMATED VOICE: I'm doing
great, thanks for asking.
Anything I can help with?
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: Can
you please tell me
how is the weather going
to be tomorrow in Krakow?
Always needs a--
[APPLAUSE]
I don't think if you
upload it will work.
Can you please tell me
how is the weather going
to be tomorrow in Krakow?
AUTOMATED VOICE: It will be
partly cloudy there tomorrow
in Krakow with a high of 18 and
a low of 10 degrees Celsius.
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI:
So as you see, this
is a rather more
natural language,
longer types of
questions, as opposed
to when you type on a machine
you say, weather, Krakow,
tomorrow.
Here I use a rather long
sentence in a conversation way.
So we're trying to
understand then--
there is machine
learning behind which
understands that that sentence
is the same thing as weather
Krakow tomorrow.
So let's do more questions.
Show me tourist
attractions in Krakow.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Attractions in Krakow
include Wieliczka Salt Mine,
Wawel Castle, Ojcow National
Park, and others.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: OK, so these
are more popular questions,
about weather or attractions.
But now I want to show
you how we actually
try to expand its answering
capabilities to really more
specific and long tail
type of questions.
For example, show me a list
of rides in Europa Park.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Europa Park's rides
include Blue Fire, Silver
Star, Wodan Timburcoaster,
and others.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So we
even know about the rides
in an attraction park.
Now I'm going to ask questions
about one particular ride
there.
What is the height
restriction for Blue Fire?
AUTOMATED VOICE: You must
be at least 1.31 meters
tall to ride Blue Fire.
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: Thanks.
So what I'm trying to
show here is that, I mean,
the range of examples I
can share is really big.
But we really are
trying to expand
to a long, wide
range of questions,
and that's what you expect
from an ultimate assistant.
Now, the next example
I'm showing you
and actually across
my demos, it's
a mixture of things which
is live and launched,
and some of the things
which is not yet launched,
but is our internal
prototypes that we have.
And they're going to launch
either in the next few months,
and in some cases next year.
So the next one is
one of them, which
we're trying to handle more
complex natural language,
understanding.
What is the name of the movie
where Tom Cruise acts in it,
and he plays pool, and while
he plays pool he dances?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here
is some information
about "The Color of Money."
Former pool hustler
Felson decides
he wants to return to the game--
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So this
is possible through merging
the power of search, the signals
coming from Google Search,
with machine learning.
It's a really combined
system which is
capable of doing these things.
We can see the
cast, for example.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Its cast
includes Paul Newman,
Tom Cruise, and 47 others.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So
now let me show you
how this voice
interface could be
used for connecting
to other services,
from first party Google or
type of others outside Google.
So first I will show
an example of how
the integration with
Translate could look
like in this Assistant world.
Be my Vietnamese translator.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Understood.
I will translate all
your following messages
to Vietnamese.
To stop just say,
stop translation.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: Hey,
I have a problem.
Can you help me?
AUTOMATED VOICE:
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: I lost
my luggage in the train.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI:
Stop translation.
AUTOMATED VOICE: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI:
So you see that you
can use this natural
language and talking,
and get connected to these
services and applications.
Now I show another example, this
time with Street View, again,
to show a combination
of voice input
and the natural language
understanding connected
to this service.
So in this case I
would say something
like, I would like to be on
the top of Eiffel Tower now.
Can you please bring me there?
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Opening Street View.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: We actually
call this project internally
Teleport.
[APPLAUSE]
I think that's as good as
we can do for Teleport.
So now I want to show you how
this could be, for example,
integrated within service which
is not developed at Google.
Talk to WebMD.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Sure, getting WebMD.
Welcome to WebMD.
I can tell you about
health conditions, drugs,
or even side effects.
What would you like to know?
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: What are
the side effects of aspirin?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here's
a summary from RxList.
Severe nausea, vomiting,
or stomach pain,
coughing up blood or vomit
that looks like coffee grounds,
fever lasting longer than
three days, and more.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI:
It actually failed.
We can try one more time maybe.
What are the side
effects of aspirin?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here's
a summary from Rx--
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: OK, so
but you know it works.
I guess you are
developing this, too.
But really, in the
core of what we need
is also to be able to talk to
different services developed
and merged by actions on Google
Platform to the Assistant
itself.
So in the next
part of my demos, I
want to show you how
the Assistant should
be ultra personal,
because this is
a kind of a personal assistant.
So there are answers and
things which Assistant
could do about the
world for me, but we
want it to also be
answering things
which are specific to me.
For example, I can
do things like,
how is the traffic from
Zurich airport to my home?
AUTOMATED VOICE: There's light
traffic from Zurich airport--
ZRH-- to your home, so it
should take 43 minutes.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So
I don't need to say
what's the address of my home,
because my assistant knows
that.
And that's helpful for me.
I can ask for things like,
when is my flight today?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Your flight is
Lufthansa flight 1625 to Munich
which leaves today at 4:50 PM.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: Note
that these are all
happening automatic, and through
a different machine learning
system, detecting
that from Gmail.
We also have ways to do
explicit, in an explicit way.
For example, if I say,
how is my team doing?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Barcelona
is second in group A.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: This
is only the beginning.
But--
[APPLAUSE]
I think that these are
all the Barcelona fans.
But I think the
reason that I actually
can do that is because
I explicitly said this.
So I can say something like,
what is my favorite team?
AUTOMATED VOICE: You told
me that you like Barcelona.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So I explicitly
said I like Barcelona one
day, actually, I think few
months back, to the Assistant.
And from that moment,
she actually, if I say,
what's my favorite team,
or how is my team doing,
it considers Barcelona.
OK, so now I want to
show you-- this is a way
that we can actually improve
the Assistant by teaching
something to it,
like about myself.
I'm going to show you a more
fancy version of that, which is
potentially coming next year.
When the weather is
more than 25 degrees,
I can swim in the
lake of Zurich.
AUTOMATED VOICE: OK, understood.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: Can I
swim in the lake of Zurich
this weekend?
AUTOMATED VOICE: No, you can't.
The temperature is
less than 25 degrees.
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: What's the
weather in Zurich this weekend?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here's
the forecast for Zurich.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So that's
kind of things that really,
if you think about a personal
assistant which you can improve
it through natural
language, this
is really going to be much
more powerful and easier
to use for many people.
So the next part of my demo is
I want to talk about context.
Context is very important.
The different
meanings of context
is used to make the interactions
with the Assistant easier
and more natural.
And we use it in
different places.
One of the places
that we use context
is speech recognition itself,
trying to understand the words.
So know I try to say an
example where first I
don't give it a context.
Normally it fails.
And then I will try to
give context and see
whether it works or not.
Something like, how
high is the Rysy?
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Here's what I found.
The--
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: How
high is the Rysy?
So the point here is that
if I don't give context,
it's hard to-- and it
even hangs sometimes.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here's
the forecast for Zurich.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: OK.
[LAUGHTER] It tries
to do something,
because it doesn't
understand what it says.
Now, let's see what happens
if I give some context to it.
Something like, highest
Tatra mountains.
AUTOMATED VOICE: High Tatras
includes Lomnicky stit, Rysy,
Gerlachovsky stit,
and other mountains.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So as you
see, now there is a Rysy there.
So this time now
I'm going to ask
and hopefully it should work.
How high is the Rysy?
AUTOMATED VOICE: I can
search the web for answers.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI:
Highest Tatra mountains.
AUTOMATED VOICE: High Tatras
includes Lomnicky stit--
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: How
high is the Rysy?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Rysy
is 2,503 meters tall.
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So this
shows that contextual voice
recognition is actually
going to play a big role.
Because people
actually always try
to continue talking about
things which is related,
and things which
is also personal,
and location specific,
contextually relevance.
Now, let me show you
another usage of context
when context is used to
understand the entities itself.
For example, pictures of Thomas.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Check
out these pictures.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: I
think without a context,
that's perhaps the best
we can come up with.
Bayern Munich team roster.
AUTOMATED VOICE: The
roster for FC Bayern Munich
includes Robert Lewandowski,
James Rodriguez, Aryan Robin,
and others.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So you
see some Thomas is here.
Pictures of Thomas.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Pictures
of Thomas Muller.
Here you are.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So
in the context of--
[APPLAUSE]
In the context of the
previous sentence,
then Tomas should be interpreted
as the different entity
in this case.
Now I want to show you
how context is helping
to follow on conversations.
Something like, where is
the Empire State Building?
AUTOMATED VOICE: The address
for Empire State Building
is Empire State Building,
350 Fifth Avenue, New York,
New York, 1--
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: I
want to see pictures.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Pictures of
the Empire State Building.
OK.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: How tall is it?
AUTOMATED VOICE: The
Empire State Building
is 381 meters tall.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: Who built it?
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Steric Corporation.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: When?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Construction
for the Empire State Building
started in March 17th, 1930.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: What are
the Italian restaurants
around there?
AUTOMATED VOICE: I
found a few places.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI:
Call the first one.
It's in New York.
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Calling Ai Fiori.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So
you can see that I'm
having the conversation
back and forth with--
I will stop there.
[APPLAUSE]
So you can that I
said like seven,
eight sentences about the
Empire State Building,
I mentioned only one time.
And this is all thanks
to the power of context
and trying to put context
into the conversational
understanding.
So this is much more getting
closer to how people talk.
Still there is lots of
problems to be solved there,
but we're excited about these
steps in the right direction.
Now I want to show next another
example of context, which
is context of what you see.
So for that, I'm
basically trying
to show some examples of
integration of Google Lens
with the Assistant,
where we're adding
visual input to the Assistant.
I don't know whether
you're seeing here,
now I'm putting an apple here.
And I'm going to the Google
Lens part of the Assistant.
And I will ask, how many
calories does it have?
AUTOMATED VOICE: There are 95
calories in one medium apple.
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: This is an
experience that you can have,
where you have visual input
and voice input together.
So let me just try to show
you one other example.
I can try to get some money.
[? That much ?] input, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, this is visible, yeah.
How much is this in Swiss franc?
AUTOMATED VOICE:
250 polish zloties
equals 67 Swiss
francs and 10 rappen.
[APPLAUSE]
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So
you can see that--
and this combination
can be very useful.
I was actually the other day
walking in Krakow yesterday,
seeing buildings, and
trying to take pictures.
I would go to the Google
Lens and try to ask questions
about what I was seeing around.
And that's going to be
more powerful experiences
for this future
of the Assistant.
The last example
I want to show you
is, because speech
recognition often
worked here, I want
to show you also
that we have worked on
improving speech recognition
in a noisy environment.
So for that I need your help.
And the setup will be
that we will cut my mic,
and I will ask all of you to
make as much noise as you can.
Your mission should
be to make me fail.
And I will ask a question
like my favorite team,
when my favorite
team is playing next.
And yeah, we can
even put some music
to make the noise to be higher.
It's OK if I fail,
it's just fine.
Let's do it.
So please make as
much noise as you can,
and please cut the mic.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Barcelona's next match
is on Saturday at 8:45 PM when
they will take on the Espanol.
BEHSHAD BEZHADI: So we
actually have spent--
can I have the mic back?
Yeah.
We actually have
spent lots of time
on trying to improve
speech recognition
in noisy environments,
added lots
of data to the machine learning
systems behind automatically
generated noise, like fake noise
of stadium, or people, or cars.
And that's how we have
actually significantly managed
to improve this.
Thank you, camera man.
So I can go back
to my slides for--
thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So what you have
seen in these demos
is actually a collection of lots
of technologies going behind.
Lots of it is actually being
built in Zurich and in Europe.
So speech recognition,
context understanding,
natural language understanding,
understanding the world--
because we were answering
things about the world--
understanding the
user, understanding
the context, image recognition,
and personalization,
and many more.
But this was the ones
that I put on the slides.
And this is all-- we
believe that these
are all earlier steps
of the Google Assistant
and the age of the
assistant, but it's
a very exciting moment.
I want to remind that I
talked about AI revolution,
and that doesn't mean Google
Assistant or age of assistant
is the AI revolution.
It's one of the things
which is happening
in this AI revolution.
But the AI and machine
learning is being used heavily,
and is going to be used much
more in many industries,
such as health, agriculture,
smart cities, smart cars,
and many more.
So it's the right
time to really try
to invest in different
industries, and into AI.
And while at Google, I'm working
and we're working on the Google
Assistant, I feel
very excited of adding
these types of intelligences
into the Google Assistant.
But I think in the end
that Google Assistant
will be more powerful depending
on how many different services
and applications it can have.
And this is where
you all can help
by integrating with
Google Assistant
with the different use
cases that you have
and applications that you have.
And take part with us in
building this AI revolution.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And with that I would like
to invite Micheal again
to join to the stage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHEAL O FOGHLU: So we've
heard two great talks
to kick off the day today,
and I would especially like
to thank those two speakers.
Behshad, who is very brave
with all those demonstrations,
thank you.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
And Ewa, who showed us the
very exciting work that's
going on in Warsaw, in Poland.
[APPLAUSE]
I was reminded of one of
my favorite geeky t-shirts
as I was listening
to Ewa, which is,
there's no such thing as cloud
computing, only someone else's
computers.
And the thing is,
when that is true,
you want the people running
those computers to know
what they're doing.
And so trust in Google, use
our Google Cloud Platform.
Now, I'd advise you all to
make best use of the code labs
that allow you to do follow-up
activities, especially
on the Google Cloud
Platform stuff that Ewa
was talking about.
But also about some
of our open sourced AI
stuff that relates to what
Behshad was talking about.
And for the rest of
the day, you can also
join in sessions, trainings,
and explore the sandboxes
that are scattered around.
And don't forget that
we're wrapping up
at quarter past 5:00--
17:15-- back here in
the main auditorium
with the closing keynote.
So thanks very much and enjoy
the rest of the conference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]